The Joe Rogan experience. Speaking of fighting,
speaking of old dudes fighting Mike Tyson and Roy Jones Jr. This weekend,
what do you think of that?
Ooh, interesting. Crazy, right? Yeah, I think it's,
I think not too crazy to me, you know? Cause I know it,
that fighters and you know, they,
a fighter is as long as a fighter knows that people want to watch
they'll get in the ring if the money is right. Yeah.
Well, while I fought as recently as two years ago. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. But that's still, it's still ring rust. Yeah. Not as much as Tyson.
Right. It's still ring rust. And so
it's going to be interesting man, because both guys are like,
not just champions, but they are hall of fame champions.
Most people that I've heard talk, say Roy is going to get ran through.
I don't know. I don't know what's going to happen.
I think it's going to boil down to which one of them are more prepared.
Yeah. That's what I think is gonna happen.
It's gonna come down to who's more prepared.
Well, they are, they definitely have different sizes. You know, Roy's a,
he's a legend. They're both legends. But Roy champion at 168 pounds champion,
one 75 beat Ruiz at, he was about 200 when he won the heavyweight title.
But he was never really like a business, got a natural hit. Right.
Tyson's a tank, right. Physically is a different person. And I don't like that.
They're switching it to two minute rounds. That, that drives me crazy.
But how many rounds is it? Eight, eight,
two minute rounds with what? That just means going to action. Yeah,
it does. But what a guy like Roy, and one of the things that Roy said is that,
uh, he wants to drag Tyson out. Like he's like, if Tyson's going to beat me,
he's going to beat me quick. He's like, I want this fight to go. He goes,
I want to get him tired. And he goes,
and I have much more of a chance to get him tired.
If he's fighting three minute rounds, he's like, we're grown man.
And I guess the WBC was pointing to a Julio, Cesar Chavez,
uh, I think had a, uh, a boxing exhibition recently. I think it was Chavez.
It was some,
some legend that was retired that had a boxing exhibition recently.
And it was real tired. And their thought was, you know what?
Instead of letting them get this tired,
let's make them just fight shorter rounds. But Roy is like, well,
this is what women fight. The women fight two minute rounds. So it got shakeout,
sexual sexist, you know? But he didn't,
I don't think Tyson wanted 200 rounds either. Yeah.
It would have been nice if they gave him rules.
Have you seen the rules for the fight? Well, there's no judges and there's no,
no decision celebrity judges. What kind of celeb? Haven't announced that yet.
Oh Jesus. And there's no winner going to be announced. Well,
there's going to be a winner.
If Mike Tyson connects on Raj face or if Roy connects on my Tyson's face,
any cut, any cuts bad. If it's bad cut. It says,
but the outta here with that, it should be a boxing match.
These are legends to get a belt when it's over. Oh no, no.
You can't have participation.
Trophies. But what happens.
If somebody gets knocked out like a winner would have ties. Listen, if,
if Tyson knocks him out, he wins. If Roy knocks Tyson out, he wins. This is,
this is nonsense. These guys, listen,
I think to get it sanctioned in California, they had agreed to some stupid.
I guarantee you when that dang, when that bell goes off,
that is going to be a fight. Mike Tyson is not fighting any exhibitions.
He's going to come bobbing and weaving, swinging death with each ham.
And Roy Jones Jr. Is going to be moving and throwing that nasty left hook.
And we'll let the best man win. But that is going to be a fight.
I cannot imagine those two legends are just going to move around.
Like if you watch Roy Jones Jr. Hit the path,
have you seen him hit the pads lately? He looks fantastic. He's fast as.
His hands look amazing. Mike looks amazing. I mean,
both of them look like they're taking this very seriously.
I can't imagine a world where someone doesn't connect and some crazy
doesn't happen.
Yeah. Um, man, this is one of those things, man.
I got to see it. That's what I'm saying. I got to see this man.
You're going to go, right? Yeah. Yeah. I was going to go.
I was going to go to then, you know, they said it won't be any, uh,
yeah. And then I was going to go down there for the way in and everything.
Well, here's something crazy.
The distance that we are apart from each other on this table,
I was going to make it closer because this new studio is a little more compact.
But I had Mike in, at the last podcast. Mike's been on twice. He was on once,
about 11 months ago. And when he was on 11 months ago,
he said he couldn't even work out. He goes,
if I work out my ego get ignited and then I'll just want to destroy again.
I want to be the Mike Tyson of all this.
I don't want to have nothing to do with that. That's my past. I'm done. Wow.
Then he started,
I think his wife called him fat and he started working out and he goes,
and I started out with like 15 minutes on the treadmill. Next thing you know,
I'm doing two hours, two hours on the treadmill. He gets in tremendous shape.
And then someone says, you know, would you, would you box, Oh,
I know I'm not boxing anybody. And then they go, what about for $30 million over
what? 30 million. And so he decided is this today.
For sure. Wow. So you lost almost a hundred pounds. That's incredible.
Yeah. He was probably pushing 300 pounds at one point. Not when I saw him,
not 11 months ago. I probably overall, no he was,
but 11 months ago he was probably about maybe two 50 or something like that.
So he definitely lost about 30 pounds.
But so the distance between us is because he was
so amped up. It was like a different human being.
The first time we were smoking weed, he's relaxed. You know,
he's got Tyson ranch. Now he's selling his own weed by the way, strong as.
His weed is like his punches there. No joke. So first,
first podcast we did, we got barbecued. We had a great time. I'm like, Holy,
I'm getting high with Mike Tyson. Second podcast. We did, he was so intense.
And we were talking about like great conquers and.
He was talking about all these different things. And I'm like,
I'm nervous in the room with him. Like he's so amped up.
Like his forearms, you could see his whole body changed. Like he's, he's like,
he's got golf balls under this, this forearm muscle. He had just been training.
And you could tell he's, he's like Mike Tyson of all his mindset,
whether or not he's physically capable of it.
His mindset is like the Mike Tyson of old,
it was legitimately nervous to be in the room with him. Cause I was just like,
wow, like he's, he's ready. He's ready to go right now. And I'm like,
you know what? I'm going to make my table a little wider.
Because if I was even close.
To him than this, cause this is the exact distance of the old table.
But the new table is like, I'm going to make it about like a foot closer.
But if I was a foot closer to Mike like this, I probably be nervous.
I'd be more.
Nervous, actually knows.
It was Mike Tyson. He was so intense.
I'm like in order for me to do my best job of communicating with people,
if in case I'm across from some, you know, like amped up killer,
like Mike Tyson, you know, you just naturally, I mean,
it's not like a thing where he's going to hurt me, but you, you get nervous.
I mean he, he and Jamie said it best after he left.
You were like that a totally different.
You were nervous too. Wasn't that close? I know Matt he's amped up.
Episodes of the Joe Rogan experience are now free on Spotify. That's right.
They're free from September 1st is December 1st.
They're going to be available everywhere,
but after December 1st they will only be available on Spotify,
but they will be free. That includes the video. The video will also be there.
It'll also be free. That's all we're asking you. Just go download Spotify,
Bubba.